now what do i say about today to those
guys today in hollywood who were just
like me
coming in
naive
wanted their careers to
you know they want that beautiful career
they want that golden statue they want
you know the celebrity that comes with
it they want the money and they're
getting a lot of money
because they're very talented you see
what do they what do i say to them i say
this is a serious time fellas
i say
pay attention
find the truth
listen to the ones
who are
doing the deep work
like a ben shapiro
you know
listen to these people
who are trying to warn you and are
trying to educate you and bring you
forth
our country is a special country very
special in the history of the world when
our forefathers came up with that
declaration of independence and those
wonderful words
it this was a shock wave throughout the
world
this changed
the whole perspective of leadership and
and government
protect this country
this is uh
when people say
from cuba if you want to know
if you guys want to know i say that to
you if you guys want to know
what's going on now and what the stakes
are
talk to somebody who's from cuba
from poland
from these places where
where
this
horror
has been inserted into their countries
talk to them
they'll open your eyes to what's going
on it's the same thing that's happening
here the people from cuba heard the same
words
these people that are talking
these people are marxists right now
these are marxists this is a marxist
movement guys guys who
black lives matter is a marxist movement
they admit it
the founders say we're marxists we're
trained marxists
and
these people who say they're community
organizers they're agitators
and they're trained and they're clever
some of them very gifted people
know what's going on
seek the truth
look at the facts look at the facts
while you're running around doing all
these other things it's easy to pay
attention to all the little things that
you or what dress am i going to wear or
what so and so
maybe i should go on his show maybe it's
a
start looking at what's going on in our
country
be responsible this is your country
be a citizen of this country be a
responsible citizen know
what's going on all right so let's talk
about your experiences in hollywood as
an out now conservative uh i wrote an
entire book about how difficult it is to
be conservative in hollywood i
interviewed a bunch of people in
hollywood who basically admitted to
discriminating against conservatives
many top name actors and directors and
producers who said that they literally
would not hire conservatives if they
came across them or that if their entire
writing room was staffed by liberals
that's just because the most talented
people of course are always are always
on the left so what sort of treatment
have you gotten in hollywood now that
you are so overtly conservative and of
course pro-president trump as well
i know that i don't get certain work or
attention because
of who i am and what i stand for
uh
but
i i think that
it doesn't affect me at all
i mean because
if you know if you if you know something
is right you know
and especially i'm going to say
especially this for me
to be on the right side
to be for something that's good like
let's just say to do something for other
people
if somebody said you you got to think of
yourself you can't do anything for other
people
i know that that's not the truth
you can't pull me away from that
somebody no matter what they slander
they
they level at me
i'm going to feel good about myself when
i help other people
and
that's where i stand i feel good about
myself
so
none of that really gets to me i know
that uh when this life ends
uh i want to be able to say i did the
best i could
with this life
and in order to do that my standards are
very high
when people say
when they talk about a great person
i heard this just yesterday
talk about
the sculpture of a great person what is
the most
uh
important
element of that description
what makes a great person
and the greatest people
the greatest people who are talking
about another level here who are talking
about greatest view are humble
talked about a person who was humble
humility and how that immunity showed
itself in in this life we were talking
about moses actually right the most
humble man who ever lived someone said
right
and
that's the area i'm dealing with i'm
trying i'm competing on that
level
so
i want to be the best human being i can
be
uh
and as i get older as the best example
because people are looking up to you
what's your advice for for young actors
i get this question a lot because you
know i've written books about this and
and because i hang out with a lot of
hollywood people you're a young actor
you're from not la you want to come out
here you want to be a star but you're
conservative
what do you do do you hide that do you
sort of keep it under the hole i see
that stuff or do you or do you just kind
of come out and proud because
and i'll be asked what i've said is that
everybody i know in hollywood who's very
prominent became conservative after they
were they're very prominent i've yet to
meet somebody who is openly conservative
when they started in hollywood and then
right now right now we have an election
coming up
right now
stakes are very high
uh
the country needs us now anybody who
understands
the value of this country
and the battle that's going on to bring
it down
uh has to do whatever they can
to contribute
to this to
donald trump's victory
and to our country being able to
revive
renew itself
it's a tremendous moment in history
and i would say everybody should do
everything they can
now
does that mean
that
i'm not trying to tell people how to get
a job
i'm not interested in that really at the
moment you know i'm saying do what you
can
and
if you can get a wonderful role and be
an influence to other people
that's a wonderful thing
and
and and yet you can't
discard your integrity
you know you have to bring that along
somehow you have to care for your
integrity as well so there's many actors
very very prominent actors now who are
quietly
doing their thing
they're successful
they don't have to come out and speak
like i do
i'm doing that for other people do you
know what i'm saying i'm kind of putting
myself up i've said just step back
fellas i'll take care of that you know
but everyone must do something